this is a production of Cornell
University first of all thank you so
much for coming here and allowing me to
share some of the things that I've
learned over the years I have been
speaking and presenting for almost 30
years and in the last two years I found
out what I've been doing
wrong and I've been working a lot on
presentation skills as star mentioned I
teach a class at Western Digital and
as some of you heard me say at lunch
there is a real fear of public speaking
in the world uh in fact there was a
there was a uh a quiz or a survey done
of people by Harvard University and
Chapman University on our worst fears
and the number one fear was public
speaking and death didn't even make the
list I'm like so if you're at a funeral
most people would rather th be in the
coffin than giving the
eulogy and I think our public fear of
speaking comes from uh evolutionary
biology I personally believe in that we
evolve to work together and survive
together and if you get up in front of
people you fear failing and potentially
being ostracized from the group and so I
think that our fear however our fears
really come from really physical fears
in public speaking there's nothing
that's going to happen to you if you
don't do well in fact your audience
usually is rooting for you they really
want you to do well uh but nevertheless
we do have there is a real fear of
public speaking so hopefully some of the
things that I say to you today are going
to help you to get over your fear of
public speaking because I think once you
know how together with practice that
equals proficiency so we'll talk about
some of that today by the way I really
love the town of Ithaca this morning I
had an opportunity to walk from The
Commons through the gorge up into the
university and what a wonderful walk I
if I lived here I would probably do that
as my morning walk every single morning
that is just gorgeous this is like one
continuous waterfall you are really
lucky to live in a place like
this well with a presentation on
storytelling I'm going to start off with
a question that may not seem as relevant
to it but you'll see the relev see in a
minute let's let's make sure my clicker
is working and there do you know your
organization's mission
statement how many of you by raise of
hands know what your organization's
mission statement is be it the
University or maybe your
department okay maybe just a handful of
people that's usually the case mission
statements I feel a lot of times are
people get together maybe Executives and
they have a random phrase generator and
they come up with a mission statement
that really any or may apply to almost
any
organization well there's one
organization in particular and this is a
real mission statement from a real
company the mission statement is to
provide a fabulous customer experience
by
empowering customers and the employees
who serve them so let's say it's your
first day at work
and they present this mission statement
and you go yeah yeah okay whatever right
do you do you really believe that or
just did bunch of Executives get
together and come up with this
instead what if on your first day the
presenters or the trainers told a story
and this is a true story and the company
is that you probably have heard this and
this was told at an all hands meeting in
the company the company is
Nordstrom and on July
12th 2022 uh 2002 Roy Carter walked into
a Nordstrom store and to with the idea
of wanting to return four snow
tires well the problem is that you may
know Nordstrom never has and does not
sell snow
tires what happened was the company that
he bought the store that he bought it
from was taken over by Nordstrom so he
bought it a few months ago Nordstrom
took over the store and he went back to
the place where he bought it from the
location with the intent of returning
the four snow tires now in almost any
organiz any store would you know the
ending of the story of course no you
can't return the tires you need to go
back to the company that you bought it
from but Nordstrom is
different they Pride themselves on
extraordinary customer
service the employee instead of just
dismissing this person's request out of
hand went to his manager and together
they made the decision that they would
indeed accept Return of the four snow
tires for a full
refund now let's say on the first day of
your of your employee experience or your
onboarding training they told this story
they had the mission statement and they
said oh by the way this is what
extraordinary customer service
means how do you think that you would
take the mission statement you probably
would take it pretty seriously because
now you know exactly what extraordinary
customer service means and that you will
do anything to make the customer happy
or at least you're empowered to do
anything to give the customer an
extraordinary experience well this is
the power that storytelling has and
we're going to talk today about a few
ways to make your storytelling
better so we have been telling stories
for thousands of years and stories are a
way that we can pass
information but not all stories are
created equally and not everybody can
tell a good story so today we're going
to talk about principles and Concepts
and tricks and tips on first of all I'm
going to talk about why stories and some
of the science behind it actually wired
up people's brains and measured what
happens to people when they listen to
stories and we'll talk a little bit
about that we'll also talk about what
makes a good story not all stories are
created equal and then how to tell a
good story so today we're going to cover
those three
topics so first of all let's talk about
why stories why do we tell stories in
the first place well we are wired for
storytelling for thousands of years we
use storytelling even before writing was
invented as a way of transmitting Vital
Information that we all needed for
survival at night we would gather around
the campfire and we would tell stories
about how we were able to find water
during a drought how we were able to
track down game when there was no game
available how we had to migrate from one
area to another when there was no source
of food anymore and so stories were a
way that we had to transmit that Vital
Information for
survival well we're in a modern age and
storytelling though is still relevant
Richard Branson is the CEO of the virgin
group of companies Virgin Mobile uh
Virgin Airlines and several other
companies every year he gathers his top
Executives together on his private
island called neker Island and at nights
they tell stories about the organization
the successes that they had the failures
that they had what worked what didn't
and he said regardless of the medium
there is nothing more affecting and
effective than
storytelling as I mentioned there have
been studies done on
storytelling and they wired actually
wired up people's brains they also took
blood samples serum samples before and
after stories were told and they
modified stories so there is a there was
there was a book actually written on
this and um if you want I can give you a
reference to to it but he set up a lab
he told the same story over and over
again with very slight variations and
then took people's blood measure he took
also uh brain wave samples uh and
determined what engaged people in
stories what made people excited what
changed people's heart rates and things
like that and there are three different
chemicals that they found that
regenerated in the brain when people
told good stories and told them well
number one is dopamine that's the
pleasure chemical number two was
oxytocin that's the trust chemical
that's the chemical that's generated
between a mother and a baby
shortly after birth that bonds the two
together and then number three is
cortisol that is the that's the chemical
that makes us pay attention to something
so when you get something that comes
into like if you were being chased by a
lion you would have a lot of
cortisol so as a presenter what could
you want more than this perfect
trifecta of pleasure your audience feels
pleasure your audience trusts you as a
presenter and they pay attention
So Stories accomplish all of that when
the right story is told
well Barbara Corran she was uh one of
the judges on Shark Tank a lot of people
have heard of that story where people go
up and try to get funding for their
company it's a TV show she said
storytelling is everything yeah if you
have an MBA that's great um and that's
fine tell me your sales number but if
you tell me how you got started and a
vision of how where you want to go then
we'll
talk Jerome Bruner is a educator
researcher in education and he
determined that if you take data and you
couch it in a story that you're 20 times
more likely to remember the
data so keep that in mind if you want
your data to be memorable put it inside
of a story and people are will be 20
more times like to remember it then if
they don't the sad truth about most of
our presentations is that within 24
hours people forget about 50% and then
it just goes downhill even more after
that so storytelling is one way to make
your presentation more memorable and
even more important repeatable you want
people to be able to repeat that to
other
people hey uh how many people here have
heard TED Talks okay most people have so
if you are invited to give a TED Talk
that is the Pinnacle of a lot of
people's speaking career because you
can't volunteer you have to get invited
and some of the best presenters get
invited to present at TED Talks well
Carmine Gallow who's written several
books I recommend his books highly on
storytelling he did an analysis of 500
TED talks and he wanted to understand
what the content of those talks are
related to emotion and story data and
credibility because one of the things
that speaker has to do is establish
their credibility in front of their
audience well what after analysis of the
500 TED Talks they determined that 65%
of the talk content was emotion and
story 25% was data and then the rest 10%
was establishing the speaker's
credibility as I was mentioned earlier I
have a degree in Computing science and I
firmly believe believe that if you had
enough data if you had a logical
argument that you should be able to
convince anybody of anything and I no
longer believe that that data is the
only thing that you need to convince
people and so we'll talk a little bit
about that uh in in a
minute okay ultimately when you give a
presentation you want your audience
usually to take some type of action and
so how do you do that well one of the
ways of course is that if you present
data so here's an example so let's say
that I I work for Western Digital our
company is built on the proliferation of
data because that's all we do is we make
devices to store data we make hard
drives we're one of the the two
manufacturers us and seate of hard
drives in the world and then we also own
the brand SanDisk which allows you to
store data uh cards and SD cards and um
and uh solid estate disc drives so where
built on the proliferation of data well
as a Computing scientist I believe like
I said earlier that all you need is data
to convince people so if I wanted to
convince my customers that they need to
buy more backup uh Solutions I could say
I could list statistics and say 65% of
consumers lost data from a computer or
mobile device in
2019 and people would say okay yeah
that's that's a lot but what if in
addition to the data that I told them I
included and and this is a story it's
not the it's a very short story but if I
said my hard drive failed and I lost all
of the pictures of the first three years
of my children's
life is your backup solution really
working for you today check up check
your backup solution now so which one of
these things do you think would move
your audience to take action I I think
the data will will lead people will
interest people but the story the
emotion will lead people to actually
take action and that's what I really
believe is that data leads us to
conclusions but emotion leads us to
action okay so let's talk about so
that's why stories let's now talk about
what what makes a good story so
hopefully you're convinced that stories
uh are useful and useful at persuading
people but okay so what makes a good
story not all stories are created equal
so there are several things that make a
a story a good story so first of all is
the purpose you need to determine why
you are telling this particular story
what's the purpose in telling this
particular story you may have a great
story but for the presentation that
you're giving it just doesn't apply
there's no no connection between what
you're presenting and the story so take
that story put it in your back pocket
save it for next presentation but make
sure if you want to tell a story the
story is has a purpose and it's
connected to the rest of your
presentation so the next thing you want
to think about are
characters characters are what makes a
story come alive people almost all of
your story should have a character in
it and that character can be you or it
can be somebody else that's fine but you
want to have a main character in the
story then that character has to want
something they should have a goal
something that they're trying to achieve
now they don't have to achieve it in the
story but they should have a goal
something that they want to achieve and
then to make the story interesting there
needs to be some type of opposition
something that stands in the way of the
main character getting the goal that
they want to to
get and then finally what did we learn
from the
story what key learning came out of that
story that you can relate to your
audience and I would say if you can't
come up with a key learning then your
story then you're probably maybe a
stand-up
comedian and it may entertain but we're
talking about storytelling with a
purpose and storytelling if with a
purpose you need something that you
learned from the story or that the main
character learned from the story or the
audience can learn from the story and
that needs to be communicated also so
these are the key elements to what makes
a good story by the way Pixar probably
one of the most famous storytelling
companies in the world uses this formula
in almost every single movie that they
have uh they actually there is a a
YouTube series called uh I think it's
called Pixar in a box and they actually
go through their storytelling process
and so you can go through go to that and
look it's more for filmmakers right
people who want to entertain right
rather than business people but it's
definitely interesting I've watched
several of them and it's an interesting
process okay so that's what makes a good
story but how do you tell a good
story so you've got a great story that
you want want to but how do you tell it
in a way that's going to be engaging to
your
audience well that's actually a huge
Topic in fact the whole storytelling
topic I've been uh researching and
learning about over the past uh I would
say year I've been really focusing on it
and a lot of the stories that uh I've
been telling I've Rewritten I learn new
things and okay I really need to change
this up and do this differently and one
story that I've been telling for I think
five years uh in the last two months I
rewrote not completely but significantly
based on things that I've been learning
so storytelling even though we're wired
for storytelling there is definitely a
science to it and a process and a set of
principles that you can learn that
really make you a good Storyteller and
one of the things I would ALS I would
suggest also is that you get better at
telling a story by continuing to tell it
over and over again now hopefully not to
the same
people but uh I in my classes I tell the
same story and a lot of the
presentations that I give I also tell
the same story and then each time I get
a little bit better at it sometimes
making changes and tweaks here and there
um but sometimes just be more
comfortable with the story okay so how
to tell a great story this is the story
dramatic Arc and this has been around
for thousands of
years uh great storytellers have known
this for a long time so everything is
going well and then something new and
surprising
happens attention increases with
challenges that have to be overcome and
then the main character of the
story rise up to the challenge they
overcome and then finally there's a
resolution and so the tension builds in
the drama builds at the in the center of
the story and then and then finally
there's some type of a resolution to the
story so think about that story dramatic
Arc and in a lot of the stories that I
tell I also think of scenes okay well
first part of the story I'm here and I'm
going to tell a story a little while you
can see some of the scenes and places
that we're in but I think about place I
think about the time um also think about
characters and we'll talk about how to
make characters more relatable but um
there are a lot of different things to
to think about when you're telling a
story okay like I said making characters
relatable so ideally when you introduce
a character into your story you want the
audience to be able to relate to that
character and what do I mean by that by
I mean when the audience thinks about
that character they think oh wow I've
been in a situation like that or I
really feel for that character in that
situation I've been in a situation
similar to that and I really was
uncomfortable so you want to make your
characters relatable to your
audience and when they start to relate
to that character then they become a lot
more engaged in the story and pay
attention getting your audience to care
so here's one of the ways that you could
introduce a character well I used to
work with this guy and uh and then that
guy got
cancer well that's one way of
introducing it but that doesn't help
your audience to have empathy or relate
to that character but instead what if
you said this I used to work with a guy
named Matt and he was a great guy he was
always going out of his way to help
other people he was head of our charity
team he was always there for me when I
had personal challenges and then one day
he got cancer so you've introduced the
character to the
audience hopefully you've made the
audience care about this person a little
bit because he was a great guy and then
you as a Storyteller also said hey he
was a great guy to me now the audience
is relating they feel like they know a
little bit about this person and then
you tell them and then he got cancer now
you're feeling a lot more for this
person so you want the audience to be
able to have empathy for them you want
your audience to be able to relate to
that character and ideally your audience
will think yeah I've been in that
situation that person is a bit like
me so one of the ways very easy way to
bring your characters to life is think
of
NLP so number one a
name a look and a personality
trait so each one of your main
characters
just spend like 20 seconds and it it
should be something unique so I was at a
Toastmasters and I was telling uh the
our Toast Masters group whenever you
introduce your character think of NLP
and so the person takes that to heart in
the very next presentation she
introduces somebody and said oh he was
tall well that doesn't really that's not
really that unique um now if you said
this person was 6' n okay well then then
maybe that might be something but um yes
you want to have something that's fairly
unique that the audience can relate
to uh so uh one you want to give them a
name so you don't want to have any
nameless characters in your story and
some type of unique look like maybe the
person was bald maybe the person was 6
foot n uh maybe the person only had one
leg what whatever it is that makes that
person and unique uh you want to do that
and then the last one is some type of
Personality
trait that makes that character more
related and the just those three things
will help to bring that character to
life to your
audience also use dialogue to make your
story come alive dialogue is the
difference between telling about the
story and actually telling the story to
to your audience you don't have to use a
lot of dialogue but especially in the
very dramatic parts of the story use
dialogue to make the characters and your
story come to life instead of just
saying well then I told them I was going
to go out and then I said well I didn't
no actually say the words that your
characters were saying and that will
make that story come to life for your
audience okay also use specific words
instead of general ones okay so here's
an example he was a big guy okay you
could just say that or you could say he
was 6'4 and 230 pounds a lot more
specific and that it makes uh it makes
the person more alive and real to your
audience all I could afford a used car
an old used car was all that I could
afford well instead of saying that you
could say a 199 Corolla with rusted
floorboards and a missing headlight was
all that I could
afford so use more concrete and
descriptive words and it'll help your
story again be more engaging you could
say the product manager or again you
could give that person a name Meen the
product manager just little things like
that again makes the story come alive
for your audience and more
interesting um you could say I was very
nervous instead of that you could
actually say what you were experiencing
and this I tell to my Toastmaster
friends all the time instead of saying I
was just nervous or I was happy what
were you actually
experiencing so for example my Palms
were sweaty and my heart was beating
fast now people can relate because how
how many of us have had sweaty Palms
when we were nervous about something and
that makes you actually start to feel
the same feelings so in a movie I don't
know if a lot of you have had but you
know in some movies yeah I actually get
sweaty Palms because I'm nervous of what
what's going to happen and a lot of
times people in the in some of the
measurements that scientists have done
the brain can't tell whether you're
experiencing something for real or just
in a story because it has the same
reactions a lot of times when there's a
well- told story and you're actually
experiencing something and I think a lot
of us have experienced that in movies
that we've watched that our heart starts
to beat faster we're wondering what's
going to happen my wife actually when
she watches a scary movie she'll put a a
pillow in front of her eye and maybe
just look out with one eye so telling a
story on how you're actually feeling the
physical Sensations and reactions uh
definitely make the story come to life
the client was
upset well how are they upset the client
me client looked me in the eye and said
this is the worst customer experience
that I've ever had that is a lot more
descriptive than just saying the
customer was
upset okay storytelling like a prob one
of the things you want to think about is
scenes in the story and I'll tell a
story a little bit but where is this
particular part of the story taking
place and how can you include it in the
story so the audience feels like they're
actually in the story story with you was
it a particular room was it a particular
was it an airplane uh was it uh in an
interview so think about a scene and how
you set the scene for the people that
you're telling the story to give the
right amount of detail at the right
time the right amount of detail at the
right time usually means at the most
dramatic part of the story you want to
give the most detail so if you
were uh if you were late for an
appointment and you were sitting there
at the at the edge of the street trying
to get a taxi and all the thoughts that
you're going through your head you want
to give that part of the story the most
detail what were you feeling at that
time what was a like outside was it
raining was it snowy uh what were your
palms sweaty were you worried about
whatever instead of the first part of
the story where you're just going to the
airport and nothing is really happening
you're not nervous or anything anything
that part of the story you want to give
as much detail as you can and then make
sure that you connect your story with
the rest of your presentation again as I
mentioned what was the key learning from
the story and how does the story relate
to the rest of your
presentation and then finally story
tagline to make your story memorable and
repeatable have a tagline that you
associate with it here let me give you a
little bit more detail okay so all these
companies they have taglines right that
they associated with it so uh Walmart
save money live better uh Disneyland
where dreams come true uh FedEx the
world on time these are taglines that
are associated with a company now with a
story if you can have a tagline that you
associate with your story uh then that
will make it more memorable for your
audience so for
example um if I'm telling there was a
story uh that recently I listened to a
podcast um Doug Stevenson he's been
teaching storytelling techniques for I
think 20 years I recently actually had a
one-on-one session with him but one of
the stories that he tells is that he's
in an airport and he's late for an
appointment and the tax there's no taxis
there's no shuttle uh and then right in
front of and he wonders what he's going
to do he's going to be late for his
appointment and then right in front of
him is this big big white limo and
so person comes up to him and said sir
where are you going anyway so they
arranged for it and he's in the car and
and and Doug is talking to this person
the driver and the driver says Hey next
time you're in the airport just look for
the limo look for the limo that is his
tagline for the story and he teaches a
seminar on looking for alternative
Solutions and and vert horizontal
thinking and how to look for solutions
that you normally wouldn't have looked
for but the story tagline is look for
the limo and people remember that from
his story and in fact people come up
years later and like you're the look for
the limo guy aren't you yeah I am so if
you can come up with a short and should
be short using simple words alliteration
sometimes helps words that have start
with the same sound and rhyming also
helps sometime but if you can come up
with a tagline with your story and
repeat it throughout your story your
audience will remember it that much more
easily so story tagline makes it makes
it much more easy to remember and
repeatable there's a story that happened
to me years ago on how actually I
discovered the power of story but I
didn't actually realize it at the
time about 15 years ago
I was a product manager and I was at
risk of losing my job and there was a
risk of my project my whole product
being cancelled and of course the
product was cancelled I was at risk of
losing my
job I was of course very concerned about
that but we had an opportunity to save
it so I went into my boss's office Doug
Doug was from New York a very
non-nonsense
typical New Yorker his phrase he always
use with Justin how we going to make
money Justin how we going to make
money and I was in the office with Doug
and Doug pulled me aside and he said
Justin I don't think I have to remind
you but our jobs are at stake here but I
think we have one
shot we have this proof of concept
coming up with Vodafone in the UK one of
the largest cell phone providers in the
world and I believe if we're successful
at that we can save our product well up
until then I had done a lot of business
cases for my product I had done share of
Market I had done how much revenue we
were going to make fiveyear forecast how
much profit we were going to make all of
those things but none of that would
convince the
executives and so we thought this was an
opportunity for us to maybe if we're
successful in this proof of concept to
save our product and also we wanted to
be able to get from the customer the
business data that we needed maybe
additional business data that we could
present to the
executives well I went off and took our
best people and was there in the UK for
a whole
month we were there in Reading UK for a
month doing a proof of concept and we
were pretty
successful but the data the business
data that we wanted the customer said
uh-uh that's proprietary confidential
you're not getting any of
that finished the proof of concept
successfully came back was in Doug's
office
again Doug said Justin thanks so much
spending a whole month away from your
family in the UK that was a great proof
of concept A lot of
successes but we don't have the data I
said I know what are we going to do Doug
said we have a presentation the
executives want you to present to them
in about an
hour what are we going to present to
them I don't have any new
data and then I said I can tell stories
about our proof of concept I said I
don't know how much that's going to
change anybody but I can do that that's
all we have so that's what I did told
the story about the end user that they
had and the end user was trying to make
a a phone call or send a message of her
grand child to her friend and it kept on
failing and our product looked at the
service from a user perspective and
alerted the company when the service
wasn't working and then I told the story
about the Tim the technologist who was
able to take that those alerts translate
it into network issues address the issue
and so that the end user could actually
continue using the
service so we had several of those types
of stories where we had successes in
being able to determine what the uh how
the service was
impacted well I finished my
presentation and I really didn't think
much of
it over the next few days I was really
nervous wondering what was going to come
out of that because I knew that our
product was on The Chopping Block Doug
invited me to his office again we were
in Doug's office and I thought okay well
here it
comes Doug said Justin
congratulations the executives want to
fully fund your
product I was happy but confused so why
I'm happy but
why they really liked your
presentation I said but there were
stories I didn't have any new data to
share with them they said they were
really convinced that if that
customer was convinced
and and was successful in this that you
could succeed in the
marketplace I left his office happy yet
confused and it wasn't until 10 years
later where I started studying
storytelling that I realized what
happened in that
presentation and stories have the
ability to
convince where data doesn't and I'm not
saying data is not important data is
Absol absolutely critical and important
and a foundational piece of most
business arguments and and uh and
proposals but stories have the ability
to move people to take action where just
data doesn't and so Doug when I left his
office said your data got their
attention but next time close with a
story close with a
story and I thought about that and again
it wasn't until 10 years later where I
really figured out what actually
happened
there so let's look at what happened
here uh and the aspects so first of all
main character me so I introduced myself
and I told you I was at risk of losing
my job and my product was at risk of
being cancelled so that there was in the
story to help you gain a little bit of
empathy for me because maybe you've been
in a position where you could have lost
your job or you could think gee if I
lost my position let's say at at at my
schooling like may maybe my department
went away or my funding went away that
would be terrible so that would that was
the first part of the story the next one
the risk and danger so risk and danger
is always something you want to include
risk is uh what happens if you fa risk
is the um ability to fail or the uh uh
you know the failure and then Danger is
the consequences of that failure so risk
and danger will add uh interest to the
story so the risk was yes my job could
go
away uh I use dialogue in the story so
dialogue between my manager and I
instead of just saying well I went into
his office we talked about this and then
we talked about that I actually included
what we actually
said and
then uh opposition so the Executives
were the opposition they didn't want to
approve my project or my product and
they were at risk of I was at risk of
having it being
cancelled and then finally the
resolution right I presented to them I
told stories and my project my product
actually got approved fully approved and
the key learning well the key learning
from this was the power of stories to
persuade when data alone didn't
and then my story
tagline SE close with a story close with
a
story okay now you might be saying okay
well Justin that's good and great I
really believe that stories have the
ability to impact people and I really
believe that your stories worked but I
don't have
stories I do research I do tests I I do
studies and then I've got these results
these numbers but I don't have a story
to tell right they're just
numbers every Endeavor that you are
involved in has a story within it let me
give you an example let's I work every
day I my head is buried in a spreadsheet
every day I do a lot of forecasting I do
all of the pricing for a about a billion
product line and uh I do road map activi
uh but you know there's not uh most of
it is just numbers but let's say that I
am going to be doing my um quarterly
report and I want to present numbers one
of the things I could do is just say all
right well here's the numbers for last
quarter we achieved revenue of $10
million which is 20% above uh the last
quarter's numbers and I could do it that
way and you know that's probably about
90% of the presentations that you
hear or I could do it this way if I
really want to generate more interest
generate a little bit of suspense and
have people remember it before I tell
you this quarter's numbers let me tell
you what my colleague and I little bit
of bet that we had I bet that we were
going to come in at $10.2 million and my
colleague over here bet that we were
going to come in at $9.5
million and we had $100
riding on this bet so where do you think
the numbers came in this quarter hands
up for you to think I won hands up do
you think my colleague
won and then you
say to this last quarter's numbers were
$10 million little bit of a story
probably not that tramatic but people
will remember it people get engaged
people want to know who won the BET and
people will remember the number much
more easily than if you just presented
wow our Revenue our quarterly Revenue
was 10
million one of the times uh this
happened just recently and this this
it's not really a story but way of
adding a little bit of interest to your
presentation so in the business I'm in
we I sell flash memory Wafers right
those round Wafers and that are cut up
into little semiconductor chips so I
sell those to companies and there's a
price associate a market price
associated with it that's similar to
price of let's say agricultural items
like barley or wheat and it's called a
spot price that's the price and it goes
up or down on a daily
basis and we've been in one of the worst
downturns in our company history in the
in the flash memory uh history it's
probably the worst downturn that we've
ever had and it's it's been going on for
18 months and then the spot price has
gone down consistently every single week
for 18
months finally for the first time in 18
months it went up so instead of just
saying hey spot pric is
up in my
presentation I mocked up a a um
Newsroom and with teams and you can do
this with zoom too you can put yourself
with a background and so I started off
my presentation then I said wait hold
on I have some breaking
news then I had I put myself there was a
background of a newsroom and I said the
breaking news is after 18 consecutive
months of consistent price
declines the spot price has actually
gone up and everybody paid attention to
that first of all they were like wait
what is he doing and that's fine because
I got people to pay attention and then
it was definitely breaking news that
everybody was interested in and I got
lots of compliments after well done I
really like that and people remember
that so think about so stories are one
way that people will remember things but
if you do something just a little bit
different in your presentation that's
another thing that you can do
so there's always a story to tell it may
not be super dramatic it may not be the
most exciting thing but there's always a
story that you can apply to pretty much
any data that you
have okayy where do you get your stories
from in your
presentations well simple stories that
are told well will impact people as I
say it doesn't have to be over overly
dramatic so what I suggest you do if you
want to be a really good
presenter is that you start a file of
stories that have happened in your
life and I've done that I've got a Word
document and I've got all the stories
that I can think of some of them are
just uh headlines that say oh yeah I
remembered this story right and I
haven't told it yet so I haven't really
fleshed it out some are fully fleshed
out stories that I use in different
presentations and then when I give a
presentation I A lot of times I'll go to
my story file and think okay which story
would apply and I go through them okay
this one I can use this one if you want
some prompts um here's some things that
you can do you can use last first best
worst okay what does that mean well what
was your last job your best job your
first job or your worst
job what was your last car your first
car your best car your worst car boss
vacation meal you can think about all
sorts of topics and this will this will
prompts to help you to uh think about
stories that have happened in your life
and that you can use in your
presentation this by the way is my first
card it had rusted floorboards it
actually had a hole in it I actually
took my wife one time I had a little bit
of cardboard and but it was really windy
one day and raining really hard the
cardboard came off and guess what came
up on my wife she didn't marry me for my
money let's let me put it that
way
okay some
resources where do you go from here well
here's a few resources everyday business
storytelling this is how to take a
presentation and I use this all the time
in my presentations that I do how to
take a presentation and transform the
presentation into a story likee format
not like a story that is like a
sequential set of events but your whole
presentation how do you transform it
into a story-like format really good
book The World of presentations podcast
I listen to that on a regular basis uh
Carmine Gallow wrote the book called the
Storyteller secret and he wrote several
other books also he used to be a news
broadcaster now he goes around and
teaches people about
storytelling um and then made to stick
made to stick is about Dan is written by
Dan and Chip Heath it's how why do some
ideas succeed and other ideas
fail and they talk about how you can
make your ideas stick in the minds of
your of your
audience okay so we have
learned we talked about three things
today why stories what makes a good
story and how to tell a good story
so why stories it gets the attention of
your audience it makes your presentation
and your ideas and your data more
memorable and it leads your audience to
take action and ultimately that's what
you want to do now sometimes now when
you think about in a environment like
this let's say that you're presenting
the results of your research to your
colleagues you might think well what
action do I want my colleagues I'm just
educating them well it may be that you
want them
to uh take a different a line of
research or maybe you want them maybe to
go check out a website where there's
more information or maybe take a little
bit of the different approach to their
research based on your findings there
always should be some type of action
that you want your audience to take as a
result of your
presentation we also talked about what
makes a good story
characters always include characters in
your presentation characters have to
have a goal and there should be some
type of opposition in your story to make
it a really good
story so how to tell a good story we
talked about the dramatic Arc in the
story some something hap uh every day
some character did this and then
something unusual happens the characters
uh fight to overcome what happened and
then they're there's a resolution to the
story that's the story dramatic AR
include dialogue in your story don't
just tell about the story actually tell
the story and make your characters
relatable to your
audience remember the mission statement
that we talked about at the
beginning and the story about how Roy
Carter went to purchase the tires went
to return the tires that he
purchased and think about your
presentation and rather than just
spouting
information and the mission statement is
similar to that it's just information as
opposed to including stories in your
presentation and how much more effective
stories make the mission statement and
in in the same way how much more
effective stories will make your
presentation and an offer if you want
help with your next presentation or
stories you can contact me here's my
email address and I'd be more than happy
to answer any questions that you might
have now what I'd like to do is open it
up for
Q&A any questions that she might
have thank you very much Justin so
Justin is not just saying it I took upon
him I responded that's why he's
here I know time up and anyone
can story always deals with people we
talk about character always has some
dialect but if I'm making a
presentation
yeah a lot of
us right yes
yeah that's a good question yeah very
good question uh there are no um I think
there there are no things that you can
say that apply in every every single
situation so really good stories do have
uh dialogue and have characters but that
doesn't mean that every single story
that you tell has to have a a character
a person in it or or or even dialogue
sometimes I will tell a very short let
me give you an example of a very short
two ENT story that actually does have
dialogue and characters but I went to my
wife the other day no sorry my wife
talked to me the other day and she said
we should buy an Apple
TV and then the next sentence she said
by the way what's an Apple TV
anyway that's a story about the power of
brand she loves Apple products has no
clue about what an Apple TV does but she
loves because she loves the brand so
much she wants to buy by it so that's a
story that is very short doesn't really
have that much opposition in it um but
definitely has a key learning definitely
has character it has dialogue so not
every story has to have every single
aspect um but I'm saying from the
research stories that have characters
and stories that have dialogue get the
most attention are most
engaging
yeah thank
you m mhm yeah
yeah um yeah I mean good question um so
with academic papers I think that per
that has its own challenges to it so one
of the things
that and I have to say first of all I'm
not an expert on writing academic papers
right I come from the business world uh
the most exposure that I've had was just
taking an undergraduate degree in
University so I I I can't say that I'm
Authority on writing uh you know
academic papers but here here's some
things that at least my thoughts that I
can think of one would be I've I've read
several academic papers that start with
a story that kind of couch or give some
background for the research uh that's
you know that either maybe give a little
bit of the history uh that maybe give a
you know maybe a history of the topic
and what's been learned so far probably
not some dialogue right but maybe some
story about how we've come to the point
that where we are right now and what we
aim to do or maybe talk a little bit
about the problem especially if it's a
problem that affects people that we talk
about the problem that this could
address it doesn't necessarily have to
because a lot of research of course is
just looking is basic research right
maybe doesn't have a lot of application
yet but it could address that or maybe
the area of research uh that it could
apply to and a story related to that uh
so I think uh now another thing that you
can also Al talk about um that uh you
know it's possible is that um some of
the challenges that were faced in doing
the research right we had to you know
and maybe the study setup some of the
challenges in getting a control group or
uh you know whatever happened and and
how you were able to overcome them that
a lot of times will be of interest right
because there's people there is there's
opposition there's how you how you
overcame the opposition in in setting
the study up and the key learnings so I
think there's a few different things
that you could do again I'm not an
expert in this but um those are at least
some of the things I can think of where
you know you could introduce that in
some of your um some of the papers that
are written
yeah hope that
helps yeah any other yes
uh yeah yeah good question so so one uh
you don't want to tell stories about
people unless yes you get their
permission one of the things that you
can do is and some stories that I tell I
don't give out names or I
say you can think this person's name is
this for sake of the story their real
name is you know is is uh different to
protect their identity uh so yes you
definitely want to respect people's
privacy always get permission if you
want to include somebody in a story um
and um and and yes if you can't then yes
you may want to change the people's
names uh to respect to their privacy so
I can talk about uh let's say the story
that I told years
ago nobody will Pro I've had several
managers several companies I didn't say
the company that I was working for um I
did say the name of my manager but you
know that could be a different name than
what he actually was um and so that's
fine it could have been any one of many
different managers now the story is
absolutely true um I'm a stickler for
that I I don't do very well with people
who don't tell stories that are true and
and portray them as true um one time I
was I The Toast Masters has have um
speech contests and they interviewed the
the uh world championship of speaking
and he was talking about a story and he
said you know half of the things never
happened in my story I'm like are you
serious
so yeah I'm a real stickler for keeping
with the facts and what's truthful um
but um yeah sometimes you may want to
protect people's privacy yeah absolutely
yeah okay anything else
right all right thanks
everyone this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu